hey can i ask you a couple questions
chris rock spotted in public for the
first time since his altercation with
will smith at the oscars oh
richard
[Laughter]
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
that's the comedian arriving in boston
on tuesday keeping a low profile chris
wears gray sweatpants and a white shirt
under a blue snow jacket his expression
stone faced as he keeps his head lowered
underneath a dark ball cap
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television
chris is set to return to the stage on
wednesday night for a stop on his
ongoing comedy tour his ticket sales
surged since the incident and are now
sold out later that night the grown-up
star left his hotel again seemingly
trying to keep a low profile stepping
into a car of course this follows the
aftermath of the slap heard around the
world on hollywood's biggest night it
all started when chris presented the
oscar for best documentary and made a
joke about will's wife jada pinka smith
and her shaved head jada i love you g.i
jane 2 can't wait to see it all right
yup jada's face says it all and that's
when will laid the smackdown oh richard
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
the stars in the audience didn't know
what to think and by the time they hit
the after party there were mixed
emotions i would like to more of a
straight apology
to chris you know
that would have been that would have
been great because i mean i thought
will's performance was amazing and i'm
sorry that he tarnished it with this
behavior seen a man
stand up for his wife which we don't see
that much anymore and they put her face
up on the screen looked over at his wife
she was hurt if i had to speak for my
woman you know i don't know everyone
handles everything their own way as for
how will feels well he issued an apology
on monday directly calling out chris and
writing i was out of line and i was
wrong i am embarrassed and my actions
were not indicative of the man i want to
be and jada she posted on her instagram
that she's in a season of healing
[Applause]
still though a source tells e.t will
does not regret sticking up for jada
what he feels remorse for is the way he
acted out of impulse our source says
jada is glad that will stood up for her
because she was hurt by the joke why
well chris has poked fun at her in the
past and because she has struggled with
alopecia an autoimmune disorder which
causes bald spots and hair loss just all
of a sudden one day look at this line
right here
look at that
look at that
and so it just showed up like that
[Music]
you